We will now take a step towards
abstraction, and
discuss the issue of
convergence of random variables.
Let us look at the weak
law of large numbers.
It tells us that with high
probability, the sample mean
falls close to the true mean
as n goes to infinity.
We would like to interpret this
statement by saying that
the sample mean converges
to the true mean.
However, before we can make such
a statement, we should
first define carefully the word
"converges." And we need
a notion of convergence that
refers to convergence of
random variables.
Here's a definition.
Suppose that we have a sequence
of random variables
that are not necessarily
independent.
We say that this sequence of
random variables converges in
probability--
that's a particular notion of
convergence we're defining.
It converges to a certain
number if the
following is true--
no matter what epsilon is, as
long as it is a positive
number, the probability that the
random variable falls far
from this number--
that is, epsilon or further
away from that number--
that probability converges
to 0 as n increases.
That is, as n increases, there
is higher and higher
probability that Yn will
be close to this
particular number a.
This is the notion
of convergence
that we have defined.
And notice that this notion
of convergence corresponds
exactly to what is happening
in the weak
law of large numbers.
And so in particular, we can
describe the weak law of large
numbers as saying that Mn, the
sample mean, converges to mu
as n goes to infinity, but
in a particular sense--
in the sense of convergence
in probability.
Let us now try to understand a
little better what convergence
in probability really
amounts to.
And we will do that by making a
comparison with the ordinary
notion of convergence
of real numbers.
When we're dealing with
convergence of numbers, we
start with a sequence of
numbers, and we are interested
in the statement that this
sequence converges to a
certain limit.
What does that mean?
What we mean is that the
elements of the sequence
eventually--
that is, when n is
large enough--
will get and stay arbitrarily
close to this particular
number a, which is the limit.
In terms of a picture,
here is a, the limit.
Here is n.
We take a small band around
this number a.
And what we require is that the
elements of the sequence
eventually get within this
band around the number a.
They might get outside the
band, get inside again.
But eventually--
that is, after some time--
the elements of the
sequence will only
stay inside this band.
Now to translate this into a
more formal mathematical
statement, which is the
mathematical definition of the
notion of convergence, we
have the following--
if I give you some epsilon,
epsilon could be
a very small number.
I form a band around a that goes
from a minus epsilon to a
plus epsilon.
What I want is that there exists
a certain time, n0--
in this picture, n0
would be here--
such that for all times after
n0, our sequence stays within
epsilon from a.
That is, our sequence stays
inside this band.
Now let us move to the case of
random variables, and see what
convergence in probability
is talking about.
Here, instead of a sequence of
numbers, we have a sequence of
random variables.
And we're interested in the
meaning of the convergence of
the sequence of random
variables to
a particular number.
In words, what this means is
that if I fix a certain
epsilon, as in this picture,
then the probability that the
random variable falls outside
this band converges to 0.
So the picture would
be as follows.
We have, again, our limit.
We fix some epsilon,
which could be an
arbitrarily small number.
For any fixed choice of epsilon,
we take this band,
and for any given n, we look
into the probability that our
random variable falls
inside that band.
So if I am to draw the
distribution of our random
variable, a distribution might
be something like this--
so there is a certain
probability that it falls
outside this band.
But when n becomes large, this
probability of falling outside
this band becomes very small.
So the probability of falling
outside the band becomes tiny.
So the bulk of the
distribution--
that is, most of the
probability--
is concentrated inside
this band.
And this is true, no matter
how small epsilon is.
If I take a much narrower band
around a, I still want all of
the probability to
be eventually
concentrated inside that band.
Of course, it might
take longer.
It might take a larger value of
n, but I want that when n
is very large, the bulk of the
distribution is, again,
concentrated inside
this narrow band.
So in words, convergence in
probability means that almost
all of the probability mass of
the random variable Yn, when n
is large, that probability mass
get concentrated within a
narrow band around the limit
of the random variable.
We finally point out a few
useful properties of
convergence in probability
that parallel well-known
properties of convergence
of sequences.
Suppose that we have a sequence
of random variables
that converges in probability
to a certain number a, and
another sequence that converges
in probability to
some other number b.
We do not make any assumptions
about independence.
We do not assume the Xn's are
independent of each other.
We do not assume that the
sequence of Xn's is
independent of Yn.
We then have the following
properties--
if g is a continuous function,
then the function of the
random variables converges to
the function of the number.
So for example, the sequence of
random variables Xn squared
is going to converge
to a squared.
Another fact is that the sum of
these two random variables
converges to the sum
of their limits.
Both of these properties are
analogous to what happens with
ordinary convergence
of numbers.
And they tell us that, in some
sense, convergence in
probability is not a very
different notion.
We will not prove those
properties at this point, but
they're useful to know.
However, there's an
important caveat.
Xn might converge to a certain
number in probability.
However, the expected value
of Xn does not necessarily
converge to that same limit.
So convergence of random
variables does not imply
convergence of expectations.
And we will be seeing an example
where this convergence
does not take place.